madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition devant plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de spectateurs le départ de la
route du rhum conditions météo
difficiles et navigateur devrait
affronter les restes de la dépression
mitch charles millon lors du congrès
fondateur de la droite appelle à un
grand rassemblement populaire bruno
gollnisch secrétaire général du front
national s'est fait reconduire à la
porte
retour sur terre de la navette discovery
john glenn qui a conférence de presse
raconte son expédition est dit souffrir
maintenant de la gravité elton john dans
quelques jours sur scène en france lors
de sa tournée mondiale
elton john sera content interview
exclusive dans ce journal
après le coup d'envoi dans notre journal
de 13h de la 6e édition de la route du
rhum les navigateurs se prépare à une
nuit difficile
d'ici peu ils vont devoir affronter des
vents de près de 100 kilomètres heure
mais voyons avec alexandre kara et
nathalie gallet comment se sont
déroulées les premières heures de cette
transat alain got his cette fois n'est
pas resté au bord de la route l'an
dernier après bien des soucis techniques
avec son trimaran tout neuf il avait dû
renoncer à la transat le havre
carthagène ce soir il a pris un bon
départ
rivalisant avec les meilleurs preuve
s'il en faut que sa réputation de mara
n'est pas usurpée pour ce vieux loup de
mer de 35 ans les océans n'ont plus de
secrets ou presque après s'être
approprié le vendée globe 92/93 alain
gautier a délaissé les monocoques pour
le multicoque en début de course
voici la réponse du marin à ceux qui lui
prédisaient pas que la réussie pour être
honnête dans les premières heures de la
course on a joué la valse des
prétendants
francis joyon sur banque populaire
laurent bourgnon et sa primagaz nous ont
fait le coup du chassé croisé alors
qu'elle quelques bords de la toujours en
embuscade
loïck peyron attend son heure
pris un départ relativement prudent avec
toi mais tu es mons un peu moins de 10
de tous les os dont il va tranquillement
cette fois ci et puis et puis par las
vegas un petit peu c'est un peu
angoissant savoir de il répond prévoir
mais parfaitement et puis tout va bien
pour la porte
cette année les monocoques n'ont pas
laissé la vedette aux multicoques
thomas coville à la barre d'aquitaine
innovation catherine chabaud sur son
navire jaune flambant neufs ont régaté
bord à bord avant que coville le marin
aux faux airs de petit prince ne prenne
le dessus
des ennuis aussi pour charlie capelle
frédéric l'escaut et yvan bourgnon qui
ont dû rentrer au port pour réparer mais
la route ne fait que commencer
où et sans dépasser la tempête qui
s'annonce voilà qui promet un rom très
corsé au large des côtes bretonnes une
vedette accompagnatrices qui suivait le
départ de cette compétition avec à son
bord plusieurs dizaines de personnes a
été victime d'un incendie le feu a pris
dans les machines du bateau une épaisse
fumée blanche se dégageait de la vedette
des canots de sauvetage ont
immédiatement été lancées à la mer comme
vous le voyez l'évacuation des passagers
s'est fait dans le calme
cet incendie fort heureusement n'a fait
aucun blessé
pour la plus célèbre des transats en
solitaire plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de personnes malgré le vent et la pluie
se sont rendus au cap fréhel pour
assister au départ de la route du rhum
le cap fréhel qui le traditionnel lieu
de rassemblement où se trouvait nous
reporter jacques devaux et gabriel
camilla difficile en effet de se
retrouver parmi les milliers de
spectateurs massés sur les falaises du
cap fréhel
on estime que 70 mille personnes sont
venues malgré le vent et la pluie suivre
le spectacle
oui nous on est perché certainement
trouver le bon endroit
certains sont arrivés au lever du jour
et pour tromper la tente on suit le
début de course à la radio au passage
des concurrents à la boue et les
spectateurs en connaisseurs apprécient
les revienne en arrière pour ses labos
et alors ça nous donne du temps de
deux derniers non c'est pas mal taillée
tourner le spectacle va durer ainsi deux
heures mais certains ont tout de même
des regrets on devait sur l'eau nous
vivons est la météo et nous on a dansé
des carabistouilles il n'ya pas le vent
il annonçait la 1 15 heures les
principaux concurrents sont passés la
foule quitte les lieux
oubliant les derniers du classement au
loin les skippers se retrouve seul face
à l'océan
pour la première fois la route du rhum
sera filmé en continu des images
imprenable seront filmées et
retransmises par olivier de kersauson à
bord d'un tribun trimaran spécialement
conçu pour l'occasion olivier de
kersauson que nous rejoignons quelque
part en mer près des concurrents bonsoir
vous trouvez-vous actuellement nous
sommes devons être tall au large de
l'île vierge au large de l'île vierge et
on a laissé passer devant nous la tête
de la flotte
aprr a vu à la tombée du jour francis
joyon est pour ainsi dire en tête
pendant c'est que l'instance est
rattrapé par la platé petit bateau qu'on
va voir au lever du jour la nuit tombée
elle commence est hostile les vents
dépassent les 29 30 noeuds le clapot et
très bien formés et on sent que le
mauvais temps arrive alors racontez nous
exactement de quelle façon vous vous
travaillez c'est en fait une formidable
prouesse technique une façon de voir la
verte comme nous ne l'avons jamais vu
c'est à dire que nous nous avons un
bateau qui a les capacités de vitesse
importante qui est capable de suivre une
course de filmer à bord nous sommes 10 5
main et cinq techniciens qui y passent
leur temps à tourner et monter et
transmettre les images que nous pouvons
tourner et je pense que le
d'après ce que j'ai pu voir les images
clause que nous avons pu voir que même
moi j'avais rarement vu
parce qu'en course on n'arrive pas
toujours à approcher les bateaux aussi
prêts à voir leur passage dans l'eau
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure je pense
que ça va permettre à beaucoup de gens
de découvrir les qualités de la course
de l'année c'est le courage qu'il faut
pour la faire l'endurance la qualité des
bateaux et la qualité des marins et non
pas la pollution bruyante du trouble du
calme et qui ont le don peuvent se
réclamer certains solitaires je pense
que nous restons discrets et en même
temps nous permettons à tant de gens de
voir la beauté la force de ce sport
merci à 10 et 2 car ces gens de toutes
ces précisions et bonne chance à vous
puisque vous avez donc suivre la transat
tout au long de cette course durant les
quinze jours à venir et en amérique
centrale de nombreuses régions sont
encore coupés de tout secours des
dizaines de milliers de survivants
doivent désormais faire face à la famine
et aux risques d'épidémies au nicaragua
notamment nos équipes se sont rendues
dans la deuxième ville du pays
totalement ensevelies sous la boue
olivier galzi philippe jasmin ce sont
les premières images de willy ou ce
qu'il en reste une commune de 10000
habitants plantée sur les rives du rio
coco depuis que mitch est passé la ville
est figé dans la boue
c'était une crue terrible heureusement
on l'a vu à temps on s'est sauvé par
miracle mais les berges sont totalement
détruites depuis dix jours sont passés
et 9000 personnes dont la moitié
d'enfants sont toujours sans abri sans
eau potable
comment est ce que vous faites pour
réorganiser la vie maintenant on attend
que le maire ne nous aide
on reconstruire nos maisons qu'ils ne
donnent un terrain en attendant on
nettoie la mairie pour y vendre une fois
nettoyé la mairie sera donc le 19e
refuse de la ville pour les familles 100
maisons sur les berges le rio coco a
retrouvé son calme
les eaux du fleuve hier meurtrières sont
redevenu indispensable à la survie
c'est l'eau qu'on utilise pour laver
pour boire on n'a rien d'autre
elle est sale mais on n'a pas de chlore
on n'a rien on ne nous a rien donné et
la nourriture manquent aussi les
réserves ont pourri dans la boue seul
lien avec le reste du monde
l'hélicoptère sa venue trop rare est
toujours un événement sur le stade de
willy un espoir pour ceux qui manquent
encore de tous difficile de dire combien
de personnes sont mortes exactement dans
les environs de willy d'ailleurs les
autorités ont renoncé ce qui compte pour
l'instant c'est d'apporter de l'eau et
de la nourriture qui manque toujours
et puis aussi d'apporter de l'aide à ces
villages indiens sur les bords du fleuve
dont on n'a toujours pas de nouvelles
depuis le passage du cyclone une
rejoignent maintenant direct de managua
hervé brusini bonsoir pourriez-vous nous
dire quelle est la situation sanitaire
sur place à l'heure qu'il est sale et
béatrice le nicaragua reprend
aujourd'hui des allures d'archipel
archipel de la mort d'abord avec au nord
du pays sur les pentes du volcan casita
des dizaines de cadavres qui sont encore
à l'air libre
et tout cela bien sûr provoque
énormément de catastrophe sanitaire
le désespoir des gens qui sont affamés
les conduites à consommer de la viande
infectée à boire de l'eau boueuse
regardez ces images que nous avons
tourné aujourd'hui même à managua dans
la capitale cela c'est l'archipel de la
misère
ils sont dix mille à s'être déplacés
d'une dizaine de kilomètres dix mille
sans abri qui habitait au bord du lac
managua situé dans la ville et la simple
cru du lac a provoqué ce mini exode
et là aussi les problèmes sanitaires
sont fort préoccupant l' alerte
épidémiologique qui a été déclenchée par
le gouvernement devra durer au moins six
mois dans tout le pays béatrice le
relais de l'international on a vu a mis
du temps à s'organiser maintenant à cela
s'ajoute la la mise en cause du
gouvernement du nicaragua qu'il ne
serait pas à la hauteur du temps oui
c'est ce qui se dit ici on assiste à un
début de polémique politique
effectivement l'efficacité de l'aide
géré par le gouvernement est sévèrement
critiquée par l'opposition politique
l'opposition sandiniste l'aide
internationale vous l'avez dit s'est
mise en branle lentement mais son
application concrète sur le terrain est
tout aussi problématique
les démineurs français vous savez qu'ils
doivent retirer les quelques soixante
quinze mille engins de mort qui ont été
dissipés
c'est sur plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres carrés par les coulées de
boue et bien ses démineurs ont pu
seulement aujourd'hui commencer à se
mettre à l'ouvragé
car les décisions les autorisations sont
difficiles c'est pas simple à obtenir
alors il n'est pas simple de savoir
pourquoi on accorderait une aide ici
plutôt qu'ailleurs on pose des questions
dit pourquoi est ce que l'argent devrait
être gérés et distribués par l'église ce
sont des questions qui se posent
beaucoup ici ouvertement vous le voyez
la politique a maintenant rejoint la
grande catastrophe
merci à hervé brusini nous vous
retrouverons demain soir avec toutes nos
équipes d'envoyés spéciaux ou nicaragua
mais aussi au honduras pour une page
spéciale dans le journal de claude
sérillon un journal qui devrait donc
être prolongée duré à peu près une heure
en france des équipes spécialisées dans
le sauvetage constitué de pompiers de
médecins du samu ont quitté paris ce
matin pour managua
ils participeront aux opérations des
dict team
ces renforts viennent appuyer les
sauveteurs et secouriste déjà présents
sur place on voyait donc par la france
au honduras maintenant la ville de
tegucigalpa l'image du pays connaît
d'immenses problèmes d'alimentation et
d'approvisionnement d'eau potable la
nuit la ville est soumise au couvre feu
une ville en état de siège ou ceux qui
étaient déjà les plus démunis trouvent
refuge dans les églises de la ville
philippe gassot
dans deux heures les familles qui n'ont
pas pu s'approvisionner devront partir
sans eau
le précieux liquide on fait dans les
puits creusés à même la ville ne
suffisent pas l'eau est seulement
utilisé pour l'alimentation
si l'on dispose de cash est ce qui n'est
pas le cas pour tout le monde
elle devra être chlorés karan et
dangereux
et à un moment il faut économiser l'eau
je la fais blues ne l'utilisent que jour
la cuisine
sané pour la russie chaque saut pèse au
moins 10 kg il faut aller parfois loin
avec le ventre creux
le couvre-feu est à 21h après tout ceux
qui seront surpris dans la rue sans
autorisation serait arrêté alors on se
dépêche de rentrer quand on a un abri
une maison ensuite la rue appartient à
l'armée et à la police
ordre est donné de tirer sur tout les
pillards
koné
à 9 heures on veut plus voir personne
aucun citoyen même ceux qui ont un
permis pour circuler la nuit
pour protéger leurs biens les
commerçants aisés organise des tours de
garde il ne fait pas bon bravé le
couvre-feu
les pillages ont été telles que l'on a
maintenant la gâchette facile
ceux qui n'ont rien à protéger qui ont
tout perdu
l'église est le dernier recours on y
apporte ces arabes
ce que l'on a pu récupérer et on reste
là sans protester s'en plaindre
la ville sous contrôle attend les
secours tardent à venir
les plus pauvres manquent de tout et
demain n'apportera pas beaucoup plus
d'espoir la nouvelle calédonie loup il
emporte largement 71 87 % des suffrages
lors du référendum qui approuve donc
l'accord de nouméa
jacques chirac s'est réjoui de ce
résultat les principaux partis avaient
appelé pour des raisons souvent
contradictoires à voter oui l'exemple du
village natal de jean marie tjibaou se
sont rendus benoît duquesne et philippe
lui dit cette victoire du oui prolonge
son oeuvre
yang n quelque part sur la côte est à
cinq heures de route de nouméa
c'est ici que jean marie tjibaou a été
maire pendant 12 ans
et c'est ici que daniel figuier passe
son garde du corps qu'il a vu mourir
dans ses bras à ouvéa a choisi de
s'investir de poursuivre son oeuvre à sa
façon et ce dimanche heineken convoque
comme partout en calédonie mais ce vote
a peut-être ici encore plus de sens
on a demandé à ce que ça se passe comme
ça
donc on va pouvoir y arriver maintenant
c'est un statut pour combien
jim amour était heureux aujourd'hui
je pense oui pense qu'il doit être là
avec nous aujourd'hui marie claude
tjibaou le sait bien elle qui vient se
recueillir sur la tombe de son mari à
chaque échéance importante pour qu'il
les clercs comme elle dit d'après les
accords de matignon ce vote aurait dû
être un référendum d'autodétermination
mais l'histoire en a décidé autrement
c'est sûr que les accords de matignon
aurait peut-être eu beaucoup plus
d'impact si c'est vraiment si c'était
s'il était vivant et je voudrais que on
en a pas eu de gens ne devaient temps
supplémentaire mais bon et en plus là on
en crée pas d'histoire on fait avec les
hommes que les femmes qui sont là haut
pour ceux des commandes du pays et donc
peut-être que pour nous qui n'est
capable d'atténuer procéda dans 20 ans
d'une nouvelle page de l'histoire de la
calédonie qu'il convient maintenant
d'écrire 20 ans de rééquilibrage entre
le nord et le sud entre kanaks et
caldoches pour ne pas avoir su réveiller
les impatiences et en direct de nous et
à benoît duquesne bonsoir on le disait
c'est une victoire du oui mais pour
jacques lafleur président du rpr cela
ressemble à une demi-victoire ou
peut-être même un demi échec
oui tout à fait presque un demi échec
personnel d'ailleurs nous l'avons
rencontré hier soir demi échec non pas
parce que le oui l'a emporté puisque
vous savez que le rpc a comme le fln
kassa appelé à voter oui à ce référendum
mais demi échec parce que eh bien ici à
nouméa le oui l'emporté certes mais
l'emporter de façon moins convaincu mois
convaincante cambrousse
ce qu'il faut retenir quand même si vous
voulez c'est que l'ensemble de l'accueil
de la calédonie a voté oui et ça c'est
différent de ce qui s'était passé il y a
dix ans en 1988 puisque ici à nouméa
c'était le nom qui l'avait emporté
autrement dit cette fois ci c'est la
calédonie dans son ensemble qui
démocratiquement majoritairement dit oui
à ces nouveaux statuts à ces accords de
nouméa ce qui veut dire que lille
s'offre maintenant une période de quinze
ou vingt ans de paix et de stabilité à
l'issue de laquelle est bien dira si oui
ou non elle veut ou pas rester française
et puis vient pendant ces quinze ou
vingt ans petit à petit certaines
compétences souveraineté française
seront petit à petit déléguée aux
territoires
merci benoît duquesne de ces précisions
cet après midi à paris lors du congrès
fondateur de la droite de charles millon
bruno gollnisch le secrétaire général du
front national qui s'était invité a été
reconduit fermement à la porte le
président du groupe fn au conseil
régional rhône alpes que préside
monsieur millon s'était installé dans le
public je voulais simplement écouter ce
que dit charles millon vous savez
pourquoi affirmé bruno gollnisch au-delà
de cet incident le mouvement de charles
millon se veut le catalyseur d'un grand
rassemblement populaire de la droite
michaël darmon nadine picard l'internet
ne figure pas au programme mais au
congrès dadre watts on a décidé
d'afficher sa bonne humeur car
l'assistance nombreuse et déjà vécu
comme un succès du congrès
nous sommes le mouvement des
propositions des idées neuves et des
dénouements politique là bas tu en as
légal plus en dés
voilà j'ai 30 ans je vous demandais
maintenant qui est pour ce projet soit
utile et la journée dans la salle de
réunion plénière le mouvement de charles
millon s'est constitué en adoptant une
charte qui affirme le rejet de
l'exclusion et des thèses racistes et en
élisant ses instances nationales
mais dans les allées les forums la base
est plus radical lorsqu elle s'affirme
de droite et sans complexe 3 bienvenue à
tous dit le congrès à toutes les
composantes du rpr au front national
dont certains membres comme ces deux
congressistes soit partie de la droite
tout d'abord un espace de liberté et de
discussions
qui permettra la reconstitution la
droite française la salle du congrès
sont remplies alors qu'en coulisse
charles million qui attend son heure ne
veut rien dire car c'est à la tribune
qui lancera ses messages le premier sera
pour les états-majors du rpr et de l'udf
si vous continuez votre petit jeu de
division de dispersion attention car
après la gauche c'est vous qui serait
responsable de la montée des extrêmes
des partis de l'alliance aux électeurs
du front national
charles milhaud a voulu s'adresser à ce
qu'il appelle toutes les composantes de
la droite mais il faudra maintenant
qu'il décide si oui ou non son mouvement
doit devenir un parti politique et
philippe séguin le président du rpr lors
d'une rencontre avec les jeunes cadres
de son parti ce matin a accusé le
mouvement de charles millon d'affaiblir
l'opposition et de justifier
l'injustifiable
nous l'écoutons curieuse démarche en
vérité que celle qui consiste pour
unifier l'opposition à commencer par
créer un parti supplémentaires et
encourager ainsi la division de notre
électorat
curieuse démarche que celle qui consiste
à réunir tout ce qu'ils font là faute de
croire à la possibilité morale politique
électorale d'une alliance avec l'extrême
droite et à prétendre pourtant qu'on lui
ait fondamentalement hostile rendez vous
de toutes les ambiguïtés de toutes les
équivoques de toutes les contradictions
dans les pyrénées-orientales l'incendié
dans une maison de retraite de saint
cyprien homme de 95 ans a succombé à un
arrêt cardiaque
trois autres sont intoxiqués de gros
dégâts dans la résidence occupée par une
centaine de pensionnaires
l'origine de l'incendié serait
accidentel une quarantaine de pompiers
sont intervenus pour maîtriser le feu
qui s'était déclaré dans une chambre du
premier étage
c'est demain qu'une nouvelle tranche du
capital de france télécom sera mis en
vente le ministère de l'économie a bien
précisé que son engagement serait à
hauteur de 62% du capital et pas moi
l'opération
d'un montant de 50 à 60 milliards de
francs avait été repoussé il ya un mois
en raison de la crise financière
internationale
eric mézil rémy poissonnier michel bon
prend la pose et souris tout est enfin
prêt pour que cette deuxième vente
d'actions france télécom soit un succès
commercial
l'entreprise publique n'avait d'ailleurs
pas hésité à différer de plusieurs mois
l'opération en raison de la crise
financière à partir de demain 10 % du
capital sera mis en vente sur le marché
et 2%
échanger avec le partenaire allemand
deutsche telekom la part de l'état
passera donc de 75 à 60 2 % et celle des
actionnaires privés de 22,5 à 33% à sion
mais c'est promis cette offre sera la
dernière le prix de l'action france
télécom a plus que doublé en un an
pour michel bon c'est quasiment le
placement idéal qui peut encore
progresser à voir dans son portefeuille
à la fois une valeur de croissance mais
une valeur sûre qui résistent bien quand
la bourse ne va pas bien c'est quand
même très attrayant même à ce prix là à
environ 360 francs l'action
cette vente devrait rapporter 40 6
milliards de francs 20 milliards
serviront directement au développement
de l'entreprise et le reste ira dans les
caisses de l'état
après le retour sur terre hier sans
encombre de john glen et de ses
équipiers après quelques heures de repos
bien mérité le vétéran de l'espace s'est
montré très poli très prolixe et à
raconter par le menu l'expédition à bord
de discovery jean-claude allanic alala
cacho la démarche hésitante d'un vieil
homme cherchant son équilibre c'était
john glenn hier deux heures après
l'atterrissage de la navette discovery
en floride après 9 jours en apesanteur
le vieil homme de l'espace a
manifestement du mal à marcher sur la
terre ferme
une nuit de sommeil est de retour à
houston pour une conférence de presse le
nouveau héros de la nasa a retrouvé un
bas alerte et toute sa forme quand on
revient d'une telle expédition
on se sent bien sur un peu patraque mais
j'ai probablement retrouver maintenant
95 à 98 % de mes capacités n'arrive pas
encore très bien tourner la tête comme
ça mais ça va revenir bientôt j'espère
je me sens très très bien en fait john
glenn semble avoir été victime d'un
léger problème de rétablissement de la
circulation du sang dans les jambes
car en apesanteur le sens reflux du bas
du corps vers la partie haute
phénomène bien connu des astronautes qui
du coup ont tous la grosse tête
on a l'impression d'avoir la grosse tête
ce qui est le cas alors on regarde les
autres et on est choqué de voir qu'ils
ont dans les têtes les plus rondes qu'on
ait jamais vu gros comme ça
après son voyage à bord de la navette
jeunes glen va maintenant subir
plusieurs semaines d'examen médicaux
avec peut-être à la clé les moyens de
combattre le vieillissement des os et
l'ostéoporose qui touche principalement
les personnes âgées sansone perdre de
l'os et perdre du muscle c'est ce qui se
produit aussi aux comptes vieillissement
donc ce qui sera intéressant de savoir
c'est si cet astronaute qui agit presque
80 160 18 ans va perdre plus de masse
osseuse plus de muscles que les
personnes plus jeunes les recherches qui
sont venus aussi évidemment sur des
astronautes plus jeune et moins
médiatisé est tout de même
chapeau monsieur plein
une nouvelle révolution à venir elle est
française est lancée par des français
internet dans votre poste télé ce nouvel
accès au réseau mondial de l'information
gagnera encore en facilité puisque le
système sera adaptable sur n'importe
quel poste de télévision
patricia charnelet jean louis goût serre
grâce à son téléviseur
cette famille surf sur internet une
nouvelle révolution technologique
proposée par deux sociétés françaises
premier exemple canal net l'abonnement
mensuel est de 99 francs par mois
clientèle visée les 37 % de français
intéressés par internet mais rebutés par
l'informatique et la clientèle la plus
large possible qui logiquement n'aurait
pas d'ordinateur chez soi et qui a envie
de découvrir ce monde magique d'internet
sans pour autant avoir des réticences
informatiques et des contraintes
également financière deuxième exemple
deux mots tv 45 francs pour l'accès à
internet plus 99 francs également par
mois pour le pack de raccordement donc
le produit se compose d'un boîtier d'un
clavier d'une télécommande vous avez
trois branchement à faire un premier sur
la ligne téléphonique un deuxième
lantheuil sur la prise de courant et
puis le troisième sur votre téléviseur
via la postérité
fellah et à partir de là et là aussi
l'accès à l'internet est très
simplifiées un sommaire en français avec
plusieurs thèmes de recherche
réactualisé chaque jour autres services
offerts le téléphone le fax
le minitel et le courrier électronique
mais rassurez-vous vous avez encore le
droit de regarder un bon programme de
télévision en toute activité tennis la
finale de l'open de bercy avec contre
toute attente la victoire du britannique
greg rudetzki qui a liquidé le numéro un
mondial pete sampras pourtant largement
favori en trois sets christophe tortora
y vous êtes ce qui a belle allure
et ce n'est pas seulement une question
de physique sa victoire cet après midi
et a été expéditive lorsque son premier
service et faute
il lui reste sa deuxième balle
de quoi laisser baba pete sampras le
numéro un mondial est pour une fois pris
de vitesse dès le début de la rencontre
règles usabc dirige la manoeuvre sur le
court c'est lui le patron
passing volet qui lui réussit il
s'empare du premier set 6 jeux zac
d'eghezée pete sampras à l'horoscope son
orgueil l'américain se dit alors que
l'orage est peut-être passé mais au
moment où il s'apprête à conclure ruse
et simon remet les gaz 7 6 dans le
deuxième set
l'anglais a toujours été battu par pete
sampras là il commence à sentir le
souffle de la victoire 6 3 dans le
troisième et dernier set pour la
première fois greg ruse et y inscrire
son nom sur le trophée malgré la défaite
pete sampras n'a rien d'une vieille
branche
il peut encore espérer terminer l'année
au sommet de la planète tennis
l'invitation au musée journée gratuite
aujourd'hui dans plus de 900 d'entre eux
répartis un peu partout en france un
patrimoine d'une richesse exceptionnelle
que les amateurs ont pu découvrir ou de
redécouvrir tout au long de cette
journée
visite guidée dans l'un des plus petits
musées de paris en compagnie de caroline
laudrin et de jean-pierre pasteur rien
ni la pluie ni le froid ne rebutent les
amoureux de l'art pour le musée d'orsay
pour le louvre
il y avait une heure d'attenté des jours
comme aujourd'hui les grands musées
double le nombre de leurs visiteurs il
en était un pari beaucoup plus modestes
qui ouvrait exceptionnellement ses
portes aujourd'hui presque cachée dans
un bâtiment de la police
c'est le musée de la criminologie on y
raconte l'histoire de france au travers
des archives exceptionnelles de la
police
très se fait d'ailleurs le lieu d'un
commercial police lundi aux ailerons
très bien ce qu'on va pouvoir sortir
c'est un coup de matraque ce petit
arriver les premiers documents datent de
l'ancien régime
petite révision d'histoire c'est la
sphère du collier de la reine
l'emprisonnement de ravaillac et envoie
donc le ravaillac qui s'approche de du
carrosse mais un pied sur tué henri iv
encore jamais présentés au public
certains documents sur l' affaire
dreyfus une gélatine photographique de
la lettre utilisé pour expertise
graphologique les fiches des
renseignements généraux d'époque
le rapport de moralité des esterhazy on
voit pas beaucoup esterhazy salon la wii
la petite ânesse de raser c'est lui le
jeune foyer le père de la police
scientifique c'est alphonse bertillon en
1880 fini les portraits d'artistes des
criminels comme l'anarchiste ravachol la
photo devient anthropométriques plus
tard il invente même le signalement
descriptif on installe le prévenu sur
une chaise de poses très peu confortable
de façon à ce qu'ils se tiennent de la
façon la plus droit possible et de cette
manière les photographies d'une
arrestation à une autre sont quasiment
identiques
vous l'avez reconnu c'est landru sa
chaudière ses victimes
il figure avec le docteur petiot en
bonne place dans la vitrine des affaires
de droit commun pour les faits divers
récents il faudra attendre trente voire
60 ans quand l'affairé d'importance dans
la région parisienne au domaine de
saint-jean-de-beauregard le bonheur est
dans le pré 15000 visiteurs ont parcouru
les allées surtout le potager classé
monument historique est la recherche de
fruits et légumes d'autrefois
autant de saveurs oubliées que nous
raconte dominique barrau chez et jean
francois monier
pour cuisiner une siamoises bernard
l'ars cherche d'abord le spécialiste des
comptes utilisés en choucroute
oui le trait filandreuse plainte
finalement est donc intéressant non
quand je vote parce que des courges
il y en a le produit marron le potiron
la calebasse la courge spaghetti la
halle au fait pourquoi aime-t-on la
courge au point d'y consacrer sa vie à
la variété de formes de couleurs de goût
de saveurs et donc il ya aussi bien le
plaisir des yeux que le plaisir gustatif
où on peut le décliner de différentes
manières on pourra en faire du hors
d'oeuvre on pourra en faire des plats
principaux
les travailler froid les travailler
chaud on pourra même aller travailler
dans les cocktails
on continue la prospection en 11 ans
bernard n'a pas encore fait le tour de
tous les légumes que la gastronomie
française a oublié au château de
beauregard dont le potager est classé
monument historique
le problème c'est que ces légumes ont
quelquefois des rendements qui est sympa
c'est évidemment important par rapport
aux pommes de terre que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui le cerfeuil tubéreux qui
fait des chips bien meilleur absolument
incomparable comme goût un des
rendements plus faibles et donc c'est un
peu plus difficile
un peu plus onéreux le marché fait
direction la cuisine on effiloche on
études ont poil garni et voilà le menu
soupe d'orties siamois en choucroute
tarte au potiron
mais je ne sais pas ce que je mange en
fait ce légume là je sais pas pour ce
que c'est c'est bon c'est délicieux
elton john commence il ne tournait
mondial hier soir il était à genève un
concert dont la recette viendra soutenir
le combat contre l'hépatite b
elton john avant ses représentations en
france a donné une interview exclusive à
stéphane haumant
s'il monte encore sur scène dit il c'est
juste pour le plaisir car à 51 ans elton
john possède tout ce que la musique ne
donnait 600 millions de francs de
fortune personnelle des tableaux de
maîtres et des villas luxueuses
certaines années la pesée à lui tout
seul 2% des ventes mondiales de disques
lui qui se surnomme la reine de la pop
vient même d'être anobli par la reine
d'angleterre je dois vous appelez soeur
john désormais non justement
quel tonnes donc était l'ami de diana
pour les funérailles de la princesse
il réécrit l'une de ses vieilles balade
dans les trois mois qui suivent candle
in the wind se vend à 32 millions
d'exemplaires une bonne affaire mais une
chanson embarrassante à la scène animaux
je ne la chante plus sur scène j'allais
chanter à l'abbaye de westminster et
c'est fini sauf si les enfants de lady
di ou la famille me le demande
ce sont de trop mauvais souvenir
pourtant la pudeur n'a pas toujours été
le fort d'elton john dans les années
70-80 il ose toutes les extravagances
petit grassouillet et timide
il profite de la scène pour se libérer
mais aujourd'hui il s'est assagi et
reverse une partie de ses bénéfices à
des causes humanitaires
ça a été un changement à 180 degrés
avant je buvais je me droguais parfois
pendant deux ou trois jours d'affilée
maintenant je vais seulement c'est une
nouvelle vie
elton john n'a plus la voix de ses
débuts mais il est toujours aussi
généreux sur scène quand il chante i'm
still standing je suis encore debout
après 30 ans de carrière c'est plus
qu'une chanson une profession de foi
ce jour
quel
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous en
rappelle les deux principaux titres
devant plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
spectateurs le départ de la route du
rhum conditions météo difficiles les
navigateurs devraient affronter les
restes de la dépression meech et puis
charles millon lors du congrès fondateur
de la droite appelle un grand
rassemblement populaire pour nos gosses
fédère général du front national s'est
fait reconduire à la porte
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet 20h50 votre série urgences 01 45
le dernier journal gérard guest bec de
ma françoise laborde recevra dans les 4
vérités de l'ambassadeur d'israël en
france
et puis demain soir 20h vous retrouverez
claude sérillon dans son journal
une page spéciale consacrée aux
désastres en amérique centrale avec
toutes nos équipes d'envoyés spéciaux au
nicaragua et le honduras
des reportages des interventions et des
invités en direct
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2